hey guys I know this video is very raw
and not super stable so I apologize for
the motion sickness my Friday morning
routine is to have a cigar and a cold
brew coffee in the morning usually
around 5:30 6:00 a.m. I've been watching
the news coverage this morning and my
heart just breaks for the families the
people affected in Christchurch New
Zealand in this just deplorable
terrorist mass murder attack and it is
absolutely terrorism because it's
designed to instill fear based on an
ideology the thing is this shooter the
this terrorist doesn't really know what
his ideologies and the reason I wanted
to talk about this and I wish I wouldn't
have to you know we did a show last
night the show is going to be up later
with Tommy Robbins and I think it's very
important that you listen to his story
but um it's always it's always an
internal conflict when these things
happen because you don't want to give
this terrorist this scumbag this walking
human embodiment of what you find in the
bottom of your shoe anymore attention
you don't want to give him what he
deserves we never we have a policy where
we do not show any of the live-streaming
or any of the video that these people
might post of their shootings and
typically we don't post anything from
their manifesto but something that has
been so deeply troubling to me is
watching the media coverage this morning
where they'll running they're all
running with a narrative already that
this can be blamed on on Trump or on
PewDiePie that this is a a conservative
Christian extremists
I want to make a few things clear if you
read the manifesto you will see this is
a deeply confused person with
contradictory beliefs on a scale the
likes of which I don't even think most
people can comprehend but it's very
clear in his manifesto he he writes qa2
himself
are you a conservative I'm reading it
right now
no conservatism is corporatism in
disguise I want
no part of it he says that he is not a
Christian and he identifies as an eco
fascist an ethnos state advocating eco
fascist I'm not hearing about that
anywhere right now in the media I
understand that people are looking for
an enemy and in this case it's it's not
really one that's necessarily clear-cut
I think that this person's ideas are are
wrong and deeply troubling but for the
media to go out right now and say that
this man is a trump Mogga conservative
it couldn't be further from the truth
he can say that he likes Donald Trump he
can say that he likes Candace Owens as
he says in here he apparently he might
have mentioned PewDiePie if someone goes
out and and shoots up a bodega and says
Bob told me to and Bob's never met this
person and Bob wouldn't agree with this
person on any of his viewpoints Bob is
not to blame now would be different if
Bob had been out there for a long time
saying hey you need to go out there and
perform acts of violence on behalf of
eco fascism which is how he calls
himself how he identifies rather or at
least his ideology that would be a
different story and it is really sad
that we've reached the point and I know
that people say there's all man you just
you add to this left-right paradigm no
listen I am conservative I identify as
conservative I am a Christian I've
always been open about that I understand
that people are individuals but we use
labels to categorize generally to save
time in a conversation and I'm okay with
the generalized label myself of
conservatism certainly as it's known in
the United States I'm a student of
people like Thomas Sol I think is
probably one of the most brilliant
economists of all time going back to
happy Smith and of course I sat under
the tutelage of Andrew Breitbart who
condemned racism at any and all points
and I'm also namely a comedian and I
really wish that I wouldn't have to talk
about this I
really wish that I wouldn't have to sit
and pray and deliberate over whether at
a lot of credit calm we'll post screen
shots of this manifesto because we
usually wouldn't but when I watch well
it's a commercial right now when I
watched CNN and they run not with the
narrative but the baseline assumption
that this person is something that he's
not
just because they want this person to be
an ally of their political enemy it
forces me and it forces people out there
with a platform and the ability to
clarify the truth to speak out and say
something I don't want to make this this
scumbag famous in any way but I do think
it's necessary when the media right now
is is is telling you what to just read
the manifesto yourself I'm reading it
right now I want no part of it and he
even goes on in a long paragraph talking
about conservatism and how it's failed
and how it means nothing and how he's
not a conservative he's an eco fascist
are you a Christian that's complicated
when I know I will tell you these are
exact words that I'm reading and I want
you to do do me a favor I want you to
watch leftist media today I want you to
read the manifesto yourself you don't
need to share it you don't need to post
it for everyone to see you do whatever
you're comfortable with but I want you
to read it for yourself and I want you
to contrast that with what the media is
telling you the manifesto says it's a
really simple exercise read it watch the
leftist media sources of watch CNN MSNBC
BBC watch watch every single source not
named Fox News and a portion of Fox News
and tell me if you see the kind of
discrepancies that I've been seeing to
an alarming degree as a pattern this
morning but I know we're all told the
thoughts and prayers don't mean anything
but you know what I'm a praying man I am
a Christian and am praying for everyone
it attacked some people saying well
you've criticized the Quran you've
criticized Islam
you praying from of course I'm praying
for Muslims who've been shot innocent
people I don't know exactly who's been
been murdered but I assume some women
and children are there of course of
course I'm praying for them and it
breaks my heart as it should break the
heart of anybody out there and this is
there's nothing wrong with being
conservative or being liberal there's
nothing wrong with finding camaraderie
in people who share your ideas it's okay
to be conservative it's okay to be
liberal it's okay to identify a
socialist and then we can disagree but
there is something wrong with
mislabeling people which is what this
guy wanted this guy wanted to create
division it's antithetical for example
to change my mind the change my mind
segments are about asserting your
viewpoint in rationalizing it and not
hiding from it a lot of people mistake
change my mind as finding common ground
no it's not it's not as you can see in
the reason why don't we we have another
one coming out two on Monday with
several different people on a college
campus regarding abortion some of the
conversations were civil and productive
and some of them weren't some of them
people just sat down and it was a
screech fest but it is antithetical to
this idea of dividing the country for
cliques dividing the country for a wind
lling viewership base on on your news
network you know I know this isn't this
isn't particularly articulate this is
early in the morning when I'm when I'm
taping this but when I watch the media
coverage of this of these kinds of
atrocities and I see their inability and
it's not the fault of all the hosts by
the way actually there's a host there
and CNN who I'm watching right now on a
panel and I know this person I know this
is a good person but I know that they
are hamstrung I know that they can't
actually go out and say no this is
specifically what it says in the
manifesto and what we are parroting on
this network right now is incorrect they
can't do that because of the way these
systems of
these these information delivery
mechanisms particularly cable news are
designed they're precluded from the kind
of honesty that our generation of
Americans want thirst for and consume
and so I'm getting a text on here and so
for me as heartbreaking as this is it is
heartening to see you
the the viewers the listeners out there
reject lies and seeking truth when I see
comments when I see tweets or I receive
emails from people saying you know what
I disagreed with you or I still disagree
with you but I read up on this opposing
viewpoint I read HuffPo I read Slate I
watched CNN and I realized that I didn't
agree with them I realized that I wasn't
getting the accurate story that to me is
is progress we talked about progress in
this abstract sense a lot of the time
but oh we need to make progress we need
to move past this well well how do you
do it how do you measure it
sometimes it takes placing baby with
baby steps and sometimes there's a giant
leap forward and I would say that the
viewership of traditional news outlets
that are covering this atrocity as they
are right now as I sit here
they're evaporation of people who watch
them and rely on them that is a huge
step forward for progress and for truth
really simple experiment guys I want you
to read the manifesto comment below
tweet me what your what your visceral
reaction is to the manifesto then read
it twice and then tell me what you think
an accurate assessment of it would be
and I want you to contrast that with
mainstream news we did the CNN 16-hour
live stream a year ago is the hardest
thing I ever did specifically for this
purpose I want you to do that yourself
today just have the media on like a
morphine drip but only do it after
you've read this manifest
for yourself and and see if you see what
I see love you guys
new changement mine coming out Monday
and again prayers to the families
affected this is just awful